was such an amazing day and ron richron
had two corporate sponsors
lowe's and zebra technologies which was
all over our race on race day to get as
many metrics as possible
and they also the best metric is they
gave a nice chunk of change to saint
jude children's research hospital
and here to talk about all the metrics
that were uh
acquired that day by all 17 runners
eight donors eight nfl legends and yours
truly
is the vice president of zebra sports
for zebra technologies john pollard nice
to chat with you john
hey rich how are you doing i'm doing
fine appreciate it so
what did your numbers glean based on
what you saw
on that day john walk me through what
jumps out at you i
assume many numbers come across your eye
gate to use a michael irvin phrase
well there certainly was a lot of story
lines that came from the tracking data
that our system collected
and rich as as your audience probably
knows that when they see the next-gen
stats data
off during broadcast or if they visit
nfl.com where the
zebra technologies is the enabling
technology that's collecting all the
data the tags and the shoulder pads
and the receivers around the stadium are
picking up information and of course
during your run rich run event we were
able to pick up
uh really interesting story lines for
not only yourself and your run attempts
uh but also all the participants as well
now so before before you dive into that
those are the black
what they looked like checkerboard
pieces to be honest with you just the
size of that right it's about the size
of a quarter
it was about uh i would a quarter of an
inch thick and it was
about yeah it was taped onto each one of
our shoulders
right right there's two there's one on
each shoulder and they're actually a
diam a us nickel is the diameter of that
usb
nickel okay and these are on you how
many players do you put this equipment
on
every week in the nfl john every single
player in the nfl
both on the sidelines and in the game
themselves are wearing those tags
we're collecting data there's also a tag
in the football as well
that we engineered and it's collecting
velocity and rotational and height
information as well interesting what's
the psi around that tag
john okay the tag does not have the
capability
to identify pounds
okay good question though no no you know
what john i i just you know i've got uh
i've got some history with that subject
matter
talking about it okay so i want to get
back to that in a second put a pin on
the
on
the football so uh we were all wearing
it uh i know that
um and so what what what numbers jump
out at you
from the run run what was interesting
let's talk about your two runs if we may
um you know because we're tracking not
only the speed we track total distance
with our tags as well
and interestingly enough um during uh
the run
your fastest run um we all think when
you think 40 yard dash
everybody's running in an extreme linear
fashion right well we only run 40 yards
well actually in your first run you ran
40.7 yards
what do you mean there's a little bit of
variance to the right and left as you're
running from the start line to the
finish line
you're moving from right to left so you
talk about the efficiency and that's
actually a stat for running backs in the
nfl
using next-gen stats is run efficiency
how much distance a runner travels to
travel one yard
right for your entire first run you ran
40.7 yards total
and of course you had a 6.03 uh 40 time
on your first run
our tags also were able to identify um
where you met your top speed during that
run so you actually reached your top
speed as a 30.1 yard line
is that good what does that tell you
because it says it seems to me that if
if i ran 40.7 yards
that that means i didn't have too much
wobble did i
going from side to side it was very very
straight extremely straight it was
excellent efficient run
thank you john okay run was a little
less efficient and you're also logged
a higher 40 times so there you go so how
did my
how did john pollard vice president of
zebra sports here on the rich eisenshow
how did my you know uh distance
traveled if you will compared to the nfl
legends
let's talk let's talk about the
explosive capabilities and rich i gotta
say
you you're at a pretty explosive 40 for
someone running in a suit and ties okay
that's pretty good but for comparison
let's use the other extreme
michael vick who we all know now that
ran a 4.72 40 yard time yes john
he actually reached a top speed of 20.85
miles an hour that's unbelievable and
his top speed where he reached his top
speed and this is where we really
enjoy what our technology provides not
only us as fans and
media right but the teams themselves are
using this information to help develop
and train their players and research
their players and game plans
but michael vick reaches top speed at
the 21.07 yard line
so when you think about how explosive
and quick that we see with our eye as we
watch michael play
uh he also still at 40 years old was
able to communicate that during the 40
yard dash attempt he was the fastest
in terms of the quickest person getting
to his top speed at 20.07
um was the yard line where he reached
his top speed
the other person though what was really
amazing to me
was ray lewis brave lewis
uh was second and reaching his top speed
at the eight
um which was incredible he stayed and he
wouldn't get to his friend zone
as quick as almost as quick as michael
vick so
uh yeah because he was the second in
terms of miles per hour uh he
almost he almost got to 19 miles an hour
and vic was the only one who topped
20 miles an hour okay and then you know
i got i could get i could have gotten
ticketed in the 15 mile an hour zone
so is it better to top off at your speed
midway through the run like vic did or
to get it at the 30-yard line like i did
what's what what it's a great question
because actually your run
um your your fastest time yes even
though you you reached
this is interesting your slowest 40
times you actually reached a higher
miles per hour
what the hell during the run so my issue
was what so then why did i run a slower
one based on your
on your statistics was it my start was
it the fact that i was i was
zigzagging all over the place what
happened right you stayed in an
accelerated
your top acceleration zone yeah you
stayed longer in your first run so even
though you peaked
on your uh it peaked at a certain point
you stayed longer in the acceleration
zone during the first
the first effort during your second
effort as well
you seem to slow down a little bit
before the finish line
where you stayed primarily in your
acceleration zone as close to the finish
line as possible during the first run so
you ran your your your time in that zone
yes allows you to get a better time um
and so
think about this we're talking about a
40 yard dash but imagine you know if
you're scouting and evaluating players
we talked about linear path and
efficiency in running we talk about how
long someone takes
it stays in their acceleration zone we
can also identify how fast someone gets
from
a star a star starting point like a wide
receiver
into their fastest zone and all this
information is now available teams uh in
the nfl as they research and evaluate
their players
interesting so are you going to pass my
information on to the national football
league john let's be honest you're going
to pass that on well
well let's talk about that for a second
rich when we looked at your miles per
hour
yes uh we noticed that your fastest time
um would have put you the 19th fastest
recorded speed
amongst offensive lineman in fact in the
nfl in 2020
um your slower time yes it's still
pretty good uh
was that would have put you in the 22nd
fastest recorded speed amongst offensive
lineman in 2020 so rich
you know for an offensive line you might
want to put a few more pounds on
um but look at your speed just get you
an offensive line group you
might consider that so are you saying
that me
as a 51 year old man running in a suit
um
was faster in my top speed
than all but 19 national
football league offensive lineman's top
speed from the 2020 national football
league
season is that what you're telling me
right now i am telling you that correct
and just for context the fastest
offensive lineman tracked in 2020 was
trent williams
he recorded an 18.08 miles per hour
speed
right and it was a play where his
quarterback got sacked
fumbled and the defender was running the
ball back for a defensive touchdown he
was
in chase and so that's when he recorded
this top speed
oh man before i let you go john pollard
uh
vp of zebra sports here on the rich
island show and zebra technology is a
partner of run rich ron and so generous
with their time and obviously their
their technology on the run day you
mentioned that there is
uh something of what what do you call it
it's not a chip what do you call it
inside the ball
what is that again it's an rfid text or
radio frequency identification
technology and it's a tag inside the
football okay tag inside the football
that you are putting inside if all
footballs have a tag inside of it when
it's being spun in the national football
league there's a tag
inside a national foot inside the duke
from zebra sports
do you have the capability of telling uh
uh
anybody say in a zebra shirt
uh whether a first down has been gained
or a touchdown line has been broached
due to the technology is that possible
technically it is possible we have tags
not only in the players in the ball but
we have tags in the
referees i want to mention that all that
information goes back to the league
office and they use that for research
and analysis but we have tags in the
pylons in the end zone and also the
first down markers and yardage markers
on the side
so this is all up to the nfl on how they
utilize the information but from a
technical perspective
the accuracy and the precision of our
technology a lot
is sub a couple of inches in location so
someday in the future you certainly
could use our technology and other
capabilities to help provide more
efficiency in running the game and
perhaps also help
the referee crew augment what they do on
the field in terms of
placing the ball for first down marks or
when the ball crosses the goal line it's
technically feasible
yeah about right now or you're just like
literally right now if
the nfl decided you know let's just do
it um
can it be done right now or your you and
zebra are not
um if you could speak for it like
comfortable that it's accurate enough
just yet
what do you think we're comfortable with
the technology
could take us it's i'm being judicious
on purpose you know we're a partner of
the league and we have to
the president the league has to be very
pragmatic when you're introducing new
technologies and capabilities and
information sources not just ours right
and so you know technically we'd love to
continue to explore that with the league
if that's part of their agenda
um and but we we help enterprise
companies around the world retail
environments
warehouses identify things in these
large environments so we believe that
our technology can help
uh provide that opportunity in football
american football as well as a sport so
yeah we're ready to try that if whenever
the league is ready to drive well you're
more accurate than an index card aren't
you john
right i mean it looks very loose i'd
like to think
about the r d and investment that we
have to trust that aren't that our
crisis
so yeah yeah i think we're a little bit
more accurate than that all right last
night
last one for you i got about a minute
left why did why are you putting this
technology on a ref to see how fast
uh they're running is that really what
you do
well actually i think with the how the
information is and i'm not privy to the
meetings that are held at the football
ops group
and you know in new york but that
information can help uh identify when a
play when a penalty is called where the
location
of the other of the official is are they
in the right place at the right time and
they can assess and research
uh that and then grade out their their
crews so i'm assuming that that's how
the league is using it they can
associate
when a play is called or during a
certain type of moment uh during a game
is everybody in position in the right
position throughout the game
john thanks for your your partnership i
hope this continues for many years to
come thank you for the call
and for everyone rich it was a pleasure
thank you that's john pollard
vp of sports at zebra technologies they
could not have been greater partners
that was so much fun
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here